لقد فر أكثر من 3800 سوري
عبر الحدود هنا إلى تركيا وهم يركضون
للنجاة بحياتهم
ما هي الحياة هنا مثل الحياة سيئة هنا
لا ماء ولا طعام ولا منزل هناك
مرض يصاب الأطفال بالاكتظاظ
معًا ست أسر أقدامهم مكسوّة
بالطين تحاول أمهات توفيرها
أطفالهم ، ما هي الراحة التي يمكنهم أن يقدموها ، كان هذا
هو المستشفى الرئيسي في البلدة ، حيث
قال السكان المحليون إن الطائرات الحربية قصفت في 31 ديسمبر ،
أحد الأهداف المدنية العديدة
التي قصفتها الغارات الجوية في
الأسبوعين الماضيين فقط ، لذلك نحن الآن
على حافة الهاوية.  من هذا المخيم المؤقت
ويمكنك أن ترى خيام الطاقم
التي أقامها الناس بحثًا عن مأوى ،
لقد بدأت للتو التضاريس الآن إنها مجرد
قماش بلاستيكي هناك حوالي سبعة
آلاف لاجئ يعيشون في
خيام متجمدة مثل هذه على حافة سوريا في
انتظار السماح لهم بالدخول  تركيا
وهناك فقط جزء صغير من مئات
الآلاف من اللاجئين الذين يعيشون خارج
سوريا بالإضافة إلى العديد من النازحين
داخل سوريا نفسها التي تحاول الميليشيات
إنقاذها.  الصراخ للجنود على
الجانب الآخر من خط المواجهة هناك
لمسح الطريق لتطهير الحاجز من
الواضح أنه طريق لا يستخدم في كثير من الأحيان الآن
يبدو أن الجنود هناك
قلقون للغاية من القصف والغارات الجوية
على الأجزاء التي يسيطر عليها المتمردون.  حلب
تعني أن أي مبنى في أي مكان في هذا
الجزء من المدينة يمكن أن يتعرض للقصف في أي
وقت في الواقع ، تم قصف هذا المبنى قبل
20 دقيقة فقط ، حيث سقط في تلك المنطقة
البالغة من العمر أحد عشر عامًا ، حيث
سقطت المدفعية القادمة من سوريا على
منحدر التل في  شمال لبنان ،
أنت تعرف أنه لا يوجد العديد من الأماكن في
العالم حيث يمكنك أن تشعر بمدى شراسة
القتال إذا ذهبت إلى هناك
بعد وقوع الواقعة ، لكن بوب أداما هو
بالتأكيد أحد تلك الأماكن التي
تقع على قمة تل هناك
وهي سوريا الحدود الفعلية  إنه
أقرب إلينا في ظل الظروف العادية ،
لن يتم توطين اللاجئين أبدًا
بالقرب من الحدود بالقرب من
خط المواجهة ، لكن لم يكن لديهم خيارات أخرى
كان لبنان يستوعب اللاجئين من أجلها.
ما يقرب من عامين الآن بدأ
الشتاء واشتد القتال حول
دمشق مما أدى إلى إرسال المزيد من الأشخاص عبر
الحدود التي لا تستطيع البلاد تحملها
بعد الآن